JULIEN BLANCHEZ: Good afternoon.
For those of you who were
not there this morning,
my name is Julien Blanchez.
I've been nine
years with Google,
worked the last four years
alongside the engineering,
security, and compliance
teams in California.
I'm just back in Brussels
now, located from Brussels.
And from Brussels I support the
engagement towards regulators,
towards large prospects or
very sensitive prospects--
prospects handling
very sensitively data
even if they're not large, and
I facilitate the communication
between the European markets
and the teams abroad.
What I want to do
in this session
is go deeper into
the summary message
that I tried to compile into
10 minutes this morning.
So sorry for those of you who
were there early this morning.
There will be some repeats, but
in each time I will go deeper.
And my objective is to share
with you some of the talking
points, some of the
narratives that we
use when we talk
to these people,
the senior decision-makers
that we need to help shift
and nudge in the
direction of the cloud.
So there will be some of that.
I will be addressing also
some of the key messages that
need to be heard in the market.
I know I have more content
than that is needed.
I try to keep it to
35 minutes and keep
10 minutes for questions.
So as I talk and
you have questions,
feel free to note
them down, and I'll
be happy to take questions.
Even though this is a
tricky exercise in public
with a large crowd,
there's always
someone that has the trickier
question than the other,
but I'm happy to go
in that direction.
So I will do this in two steps.
The first step will be for
me to go into the technology,
and then I will cover more
the compliance side of things
because it's a very important
topic here in Europe.
Before I start, I'm going to ask
you to do a trot visualization
exercise.
If you are in meditation, you
know what visualization is.
You close your eyes,
and for a few seconds
you just picture for yourself
that one person in your family,
in your close group of friends
that is still today saving
all of his money, his lifelong
savings under a mattress
in his bedroom or her bedroom
and possibly a shotgun
in the living room.
And you close your eyes and
you think about that person.
We all have that person
in our families or group
of friends behaving that way.
Or maybe we don't because
nobody does that anymore.
And the reason I'm
using this little trick
is because I want to
introduce a fact now
that an increasing
number of people
are making a parallel
between what is happening
with the cloud today with
what has been happening
with the bank world and
the banking revolution 100,
250 years ago.
What the banks did--
managed to do over a
quite long period of time,
they managed to convince
every single one of us
to take the most valuable
belongings they had away
from the silos of sparings and
bring this into what was then
called capital.
And what capital allowed to
do was absolutely unthinkable
before capital was created--
motorways, skyscrapers, research
program, quest to the moon.
You name it, this was all made
possible because of capital.
What is happening with data
today and with the cloud today
is very similar.
Gradually we receive
the guarantees,
we receive the commitments.
We grow up with the idea that
it is thinkable to take away
the information that is very
secure in these small silos,
and we agreed to
bring it together
in these big amounts of
data hosted in the cloud.
And this allows
for ideas to happen
that were completely unthinkable
even a few months ago.
I remember presenting
on driverless cars
in Europe three years ago.
You had people
laughing in the room.
Nobody laughs about
driverless cars anymore.
And these things are
coming, machine learning,
virtual reality--
this is all-- these are
all new technologies,
new ideas that are powered
by the cloud, made possible
by the cloud.
The banks brought something
else than capital.
They brought
security, and today we
cloud providers stand
bolder, I would say,
than they would stand
a couple of years back,
saying we can play a
similar role to what banks
have played when it
comes to increase
the security of the data.
And there are a couple
of technical reasons
for this that I touched
upon this morning
that I want to go a little
bit deeper on this afternoon.
Then as was mentioned
this morning,
you will all be there thinking,
it's all fine and good,
I understand Google has the
resource and the capacities
to protect the data, but
I still don't trust you.
And so this is
where I will go more
into details about what
are the tools, what
are the clauses, what are
the information that you need
to engage into these
discussions with yourself,
with your stakeholders,
with your customers
and see how long it takes but
progress in that direction
to decide whether or not you
want to move to the cloud.
If I manage time well,
I will have the time
to share with you more tools,
maybe go a little bit deeper
into the tools that I quickly
snapped this morning that
can help your organization
be more compliant
and get ready for the
GDPR among others.
I also want to share a
few of the personal tools
that you can activate right
now by the end of the day
or certainly during the
weekend on your own account
to significantly increase
your security posture,
and these are tools that are
available in the consumer
world of Google but are easily
activated on the organization
side, and so your administrator
or yourself can activate
this for your organization.
This process of assessing deeply
the technical capabilities
in terms of security and then
building the trust and this--
within the stakeholders to
decide to move to the cloud
is not the process that
you will pioneer into.
I don't know if this is English,
but that you will pioneer.
Today Google serves 6
million organizations.
Three million of them are NGOs,
educational organizations.
The three other million are
commercial organizations
paying their licenses.
And you recognize on
these slides already
names of companies that
are handling extremely
sensitive information.
The one that we engage a
lot with at the moment,
we do joint events and we
try to evangelize is PwC.
PwC is rolling out
100,000 to 200,000 users
at the moment across the
world, and they're handling--
how sensitive--
how more sensitive
can you be than tax information
from your customers?
You see names like
Charles Schwab, Deloitte.
"The Economist" is an
interesting example.
The source-- the life and
death of some of the sources
being handled there depends
on the security of the data
and how well it is managed.
When we present in
the south of Europe,
I like to bring up the
example of "LeMonde."
"LeMonde" is one
of the dailies that
has the most critical
editorial line on Google,
and yet they are using
G Suite today to work.
Airbus is another good example.
There are some names that
are not on this slide.
And there's one in particular
that is a very good example,
and normally we
don't talk about them
because we don't have
the marketing rights,
but they blogged about
it a few months ago.
So I just now refer to the
blog and I encourage you
to Google UK Cabinet Office.
So the team of the prime
minister of the United Kingdom
is using G Suite for
a year and a half now,
and they are very
happy about it.
They were so happy
they blogged about it.
And this is to give you an
idea of the level of security
and the level of
privacy commitments.
These platforms in general--
these are all Google--
these are all Google
customers, but this
is the level of security
that cloud providers
have been able to give
now to their customers.
So going into security itself
in the first part of the talk
and trying to understand
what it is that makes
cloud platform in such a--
puts Cloud platform in
such a positive spot
when it comes to security.
I talked about this
model this morning,
assess the capability
to anticipate,
assess the capability to defend,
and assess the capability
to react.
As a model that is widely used
across the security industry
to assess the security
of any system,
would it be an IT system
or a non-IT system.
And I mentioned the fact
that Google operates
these seven platforms with
more than a billion users
allowing us to test these
platforms very, very broadly.
If you think of what
the business model has
been for the last
18 years of Google,
it has been to go
around the web and make
a copy of the entire
web for some parts of it
close to real
time, and this copy
is being brought to
our data centers.
It is being indexed,
and the search results
are delivered in a
few milliseconds.
So of course, the indexing
doesn't happen on the live web.
It happens on the copy, and
we deliver the search results
on this copy.
This gives you the
idea of how much
we know about what is
fantastic about the web
and that we share
with you immediately
in terms of search results.
Also gives you an
idea of all that we
know that is terrible
about the web
that we also share with you.
We share this in
specific services,
the most famous is
called Safe Browsing.
It's a package service
in which we encapsulate
this data, this information
about the different websites
and what they contain
that could be harmful.
And this service is shared
with Mozilla and Safari,
and so most of the web
browsers use that information
to protect you.
When you are going to
enter a harmful website,
you will receive a
message that tells
you caution if you
proceed beyond,
this could be harmful
to your computer.
Normally when there are no
spots, I scan the audience
and I try to spot the
people going yes, yes, yes
because then I know who
is going on these sites,
but here I have this spot
so I can't see anything.
I talked about safety
nets this morning.
Out of the 2 billion
Android devices, 400 million
polled daily to gather
the health information
and paint that landscape--
the threat landscape.
You might know that Google
Play is a fully fledged payment
platform completely
PCI DSS compliant
that handles the payment of
more than a billion users.
And Gmail serves tens
of thousands of doctors
and medical practitioners
around the world today.
So it has to be compliant.
It had to comply with
very stringent health care
regulation; namely, the HIPAA
regulation in the United States
that is very demanding.
So this gives you an idea of how
this platform is being tested
and allows us to gather
so much information.
Out of all that
information, there
is one clear direction
that is important to keep
in mind if you try
to figure out what
is the direction that the
Google security teams are--
one of the important direction
that the Google security
teams are trying to follow.
And it is summarized
by this slide.
It's public information, but we
have similar data in our logs.
Almost all successful
incidents make
use of a vulnerability that
is older than one year.
That means that the problem
lies with us users--
us intermediate
users, administrators
being overwhelmed with
the complexity of having
to constantly update patch,
keep everything updated
and under control.
And even if your teams
and your security teams
had an infinite budget and
access to great research
resources and hire the
best security researchers
in the country or
in the world, you
know you're fighting
an uphill battle
because 2/3 of the incidents
make use of login credential
that have been shared
by your users willingly.
And the reason for this is
according to this public data,
it requires less
than eight emails
to your organization to acquire
the login information of one
of your employees.
We ran a survey in 2014 with
the University of San Diego,
and our results for
the last data was 43%.
There's actually less than
three well-crafted emails
to gather the login credential
of one of your employees.
So what does that mean
for large cloud platforms
in general and the mission that
the Google security teams--
one of the directions
that Google security has
set for itself is that we
must use our capabilities,
the technical
capabilities that we
have to offload part of that
complexity from the user.
We must resolve that
complexity problem
without imposing any
tradeoff on the convenience
that you have been used
to have on your devices
or on your systems
because we all
know that the least
tradeoff on convenience
that is being asked, you just
try to go around the security.
I notice it with myself, I
notice that everybody-- it just
requires-- it's just
a couple of seconds
more that you need
each time you log in,
and then you will try to
avoid it at that threshold.
So how can large cloud
platforms develop
systems that solve
this complexity
and avoid the tradeoff--
forcing for a tradeoff?
So I touched upon
the basics here.
I want to go a little
bit more into detail.
I touched on the
basics this morning.
I want to go a little
bit more detail.
So these infrastructures
were built
for a blank slate, not having
to cope with the complexity,
but of course, if they grew up
being very complex systems--
I mentioned these
2 billion lines
of code and 50,000 engineer--
30,000 engineers creating
50,000 change requests per day.
And I mentioned intelligent
automation, handling all this
and being able to
manage all this.
If you want to
picture for yourself
a security problem
that has been solved
by that kind of
automation, you think
about how you were using
emails at the end of the '90s,
and you remember how
email was going to die,
email was unusable
because of spam.
There was so much spam,
email was a dead tool.
If you're using Gmail today,
you have less than 0.01%
of spam in your inbox,
and the reason for this
is that these systems
are reading your emails
and have become very, very good
at predicting what is relevant,
what is not relevant for
you, what is threatening,
what is not threatening to you.
And when you know that
spam is one of the biggest
vectors for
distribution of malware,
this is a significant win.
Actually one of the
wins I don't really
understand why we
don't talk more about.
If you want to project
that into the future
and you want to think how
can this technology help me
in the future addressing some
of the big security issues,
think about authentication,
this very bad password hygiene
that we all have.
Are we using the same password
across different websites?
I don't want to--
who does that?
Who doesn't do that?
We know that's a way
to solve this and one
of the important ways
to solve this will
be behavioral
authentication, making sense
of the different signals that
we share with our devices,
with our watches, how
we look, how we sound,
how we handle your device.
If we combine all these signals
together using these systems,
we're able to identify you by
a factor 10,000 more accurate
than a normal digit password.
When we're able to
identify you so precisely,
we're then able to authenticate
you sometimes hopefully
in real time so that when I'm
using my mobile phone and I
access to call Google services,
my phone authenticates me
to these systems.
When I pass my phone to my son,
automatically the access rights
drop down to talk and go.
This is the kind of technology
that is not future music.
This is the kind--
proof of concepts are there,
SDK is there, and the trusted
testers, and we are working
with partners of that.
Of course, the road is long.
There's a lot of privacy
concerns, a lot of discussions
to have with the community
and with society.
But these are the kind of
things that large cloud
providers and
Google specifically
will be embedding in their
technology as we grow, right,
and you will be benefiting
directly from this as we grow.
I'm linking this slide with the
concept of security by design.
It's fantastic that the
regulator imposes now security
by design.
And when you will be
reviewing the GDPR,
you will see this term
"security by design."
Think already about
evolving this design,
how can this design adapt
and evolve to the landscape.
This is what these
technologies will allow.
The second concept that
I brought up this morning
was the control over
the entire stack.
The biggest concern of--
if you ask a chief
security officer today--
and remember asking the question
to the chief security officer
at Google--
what is keeping him-- what is
keeping him awake at night,
one of the things that
he will bring up--
he or she will bring up is the
supply chain of the components,
how are you sure that
the components you
bring into your systems in
the organization are secure.
Because of the size of
that large cloud platform
and Google in particular, we've
been adamant on this topic--
because of the
size we operate at,
we have the luxury of
designing our own hardware,
our own chips, controlling
and designing our own custom
operating systems.
And throughout the
different layers
of the stack all the way
to the mobile interface,
we have kept a very
high level of control.
I mentioned this
morning how this
allows for faster
or relatively faster
incident detection and relative
easier incident remediation.
Again when you think of
the words of the regulator
today, breach notification,
how fast can you react,
having that kind of transparency
and homogeneity in the system
is something that will
play in your favor.
Actually I want to talk
about this slide before.
I will get to the
other one after.
One of the important layers
here that is most illustrative
is the storage layer.
How do we store the data, how
do we protect the data when
we store it?
Data at Google is--
when you enter
information in a Gmail
or in Google Docs, before
you even send the email
or share the document, the
data that you have typed in
is instantly chunked into
pieces, several kilobytes
to a couple of megabytes
in size maximum.
Each of these pieces is
replicated at least three times
on the same server
and at least--
or sorry, three times
in the same data center
and at least across two data
centers across the world.
This is how it goes
all the time when
you use Gmail or Google Docs.
Each of these chunks
of data is then
encrypted with a
data encryption key.
The data encryption
key is located
very close to the chunks so
that it can decrypt very fast.
But of course, there are so many
millions-- hundreds of millions
of data encryption keys.
Each of these data
encryption keys
is encrypted with a
key encryption key.
And the key encryption keys
are stored in the keystore,
and there are replicates
of the keystore
in approximately 10,000
locations around the world.
All access to the keystore is
controlled by access control
list and logged.
So it is-- we used to never
communicate this before.
This is how we're
able to explain
to financial regulators and
other regulators of the world
how we were sure that we're
in control of who is accessing
your data because it is
virtually impossible to go
through these two layers
of encryption without--
it is impossible to go through
these two layers of encryption
without accessing the keystore
and leaving a trace in the log,
Then I spoke about
the infrastructure
and how having your
data replicated
across a global
infrastructure, 15 data
centers across the
world, four in Europe--
I mentioned them this morning,
Finland, Ireland, Holland,
and Belgium.
There's a slight competition
between Holland and Belgium
at the moment for who has
the biggest data center.
So even at Google--
and two more coming actually
very soon in Europe.
So an expansion of this network.
But the size of
these data centers
is not the most important
piece of information.
I find very relevant
information is
the connection of these dark
fibers that connect the data
centers, propriety fibers.
We lay out our own
cables through the ocean,
take part in the
consortium where we have
direct control on the cables.
And that makes us--
puts us in a very good
position to address latency--
I mentioned latency
is very important when
you offer a
Collaboration Solution,
but also in terms of
security we are very
much in control of our destiny.
For many of our customers, this
is a critical decision point.
We talk publicly about--
the Hollywood
industry is a big fan
of Google Cloud at the moment.
They are using a lot of our
computing powers and storage
powers.
You can understand how sensitive
any movie is and they do not
want this to leak and
how aggressively they
can be attacked.
And having the benefits
of these encryption--
these propriety pipes through
the ocean self-encrypted,
encrypted under our own control
is very interesting to them.
So this is for the connection
between the data centers.
The yellow points that you
see there represent our Google
front ends.
So the connection points between
the Google infrastructure
and the public internet.
And this gives you
an idea of the amount
of options we can play with
when you come under DDoS attack,
for example.
It is then very easy and it
happens actually automatically
to load balance the traffic
from any of those Google front
ends to make sure
that you remain online
even though one-half of the
world is being under attack.
This is the kind
of infrastructure
that allows a large public
cloud provider like Google
to aim for what we called
zero recovery point objective,
so recovery point
objective of zero,
which means in case of major
catastrophe, zero data loss.
And zero recovery
time objective,
which means in case of major
catastrophe, instant failover.
You do not see anything.
Every year Google-- at
least every year Google
simulates a major catastrophe.
So we shut down
portions of the world.
You have never noticed
any of these drills.
In the nine years
I've been at Google--
and I am 12 hours today
in front of these tools.
Once I was thinking wow,
there is something going on,
and indeed I never knew
exactly what it was,
but there was something,
there was something.
So this infrastructure
are highly redundant
and are used to offer that.
Lastly and very important when
we switch to the compliance
discussion, this is
the infrastructure
that allows us to aim to deliver
the same level of security
for everybody in the world.
You might be tired sometimes
of the idealistic stance
of Google, but this is very
important to the teams.
There is no way that
we'll offer more security
to a German than to a
Pakistani or to a US citizen.
We want to offer the same level
of security for everybody.
And so whenever we hear you want
to have data here and there,
we like--
first of all, you might
not know what you wish.
Locating data might not
increase your security.
Secondly, this is
really not what we are
aiming to deliver to the world.
Quickly, another thing that
Google has been allowed to--
has been able to solve
is the biggest problem
of the chief security
officers today is
the access to human resources.
How do you convince the
right brains to come and work
on these tough problems
in your organizations?
Even if you're a large bank
in your country, of course,
there are several that
you will, but we have
a tremendous advantage there.
And even though we have many
of these researchers in-house
working on these tough
problems, we actually
know that it is
not 700 people that
will solve security on the web.
And so these guys are constantly
collaborating with the research
community and actually
for having worked
alongside these guys,
I realized they do not
come-- they did not
come to work for Google.
They come to work for Dick,
John, who was their guru when
they were doing
their PhD, and they
want to keep on
solving that problem.
If Dick or John goes
to another company,
probably they will follow.
The importance of this community
lives as a separate life,
and that's an understatement.
So one of the things that
they are really proud of
is the vulnerability
reward program
where we actively encourage
anybody around the world
to attack our systems.
Many of the questions we
receive from our institutional
customers is under what
conditions can we test you?
Any condition.
It's all fair game.
Give it your best shot.
The email that we sent to
people that ask us this question
is literally three lines.
Give it your best shot.
We don't want to know anything.
The only thing is if you find
a vulnerability, tell us.
Otherwise we can't pay you.
We've paid already more
than $4 million in rewards.
The researcher that received the
most money received $200,000.
If they decide to
give this to charity,
we basically double the amount.
And believe it or
not, many of them
give these things to charity.
So this open collaboration
model is the last thing
I want to say because
in the world of security
it's a very important point.
This is so-- at
this point, I hope
we have not exaggerated
on the technology aspect,
and we are not reaching
at the ad nauseum point.
I want to spin, to pivot--
I want to pivot to
compliance and tell you
what are the tools that
we give you to increase
that confidence in the system.
This is probably the
most important slide
of the entire presentation.
The only thing you really,
really need to remember,
if anything, is when you
sign a contract with a cloud
provider-- whether it
be Google Cloud, Amazon,
Microsoft or any other--
you are being defined as a
data controller in control
of the data, and
the cloud provider
is being defined as
a data processor,
and the data processor
may not use your data
for any other purpose
than deliver you
the service that you paid for.
This is a cornerstone
of the GDPR, cornerstone
of all these contracts and
a very important notion that
also explains why there will
be no advertising by Google
or no usage by Google of the
data you put into our system
because it is
contractually written just
like in any other contract.
Before you write
into the contract,
you will have access
to all the information
that the regulators
now expect you to have
before you sign a contract.
What is the exact
location of your data?
So you receive the
location of data centers.
We may not be able
to tell you in which
data center the
data is, but it is
in some of these data centers.
The subprocessors-- who
are the subprocessors?
The availability
of the systems is
available through
public dashboard,
so you can see at any
given point in time
when these systems
are available,
when they have
been down, and you
can make your own assessment
there, is it sufficient or not.
And importantly,
the certifications--
all large cloud
providers have undergone
now the major certifications.
You will recognize, if you're
familiar to that world, 27001
which certifies for
computing security,
2717 for cloud computing,
2718 for handling of BII.
So these are the gold
standards on these topics.
The second layer are the SOC
audit reports, very stringent,
very well recognized.
You can access-- we provide
you access to the SOC 2 report
under NDA.
So the SOC 3 is public.
You can obtain it.
The SOC 2 is 210 pages
of granular controls.
It is also available for
our customers under NDA.
So if you really want to check
every single control, security
control, it is available.
I just want to stop on to one
badge, which is the FedRAMP
badge, because it's a clear
differentiator between Google
and the other cloud providers.
All cloud providers,
major cloud providers
have achieved the certification
which allows cloud
to deliver services to the
federal agencies of the United
States government,
including defense.
And so yes, we have many defense
customers using Google Cloud
and having the data
onto the infrastructure.
What is specific about
Google certification
is Google is the
only provider that
certified the entire
infrastructure as opposed
to our competitors who certified
subset of the infrastructure.
So they have built
specific farms
that have received the badges--
that badge, and these
farms of servers
that are serving
these federal agencies
and delivering that
kind of security.
When you engage with Google, you
receive exactly the same level
of security that we guarantee
to Rockwell Collins,
for example, a major defense
contractor of United States,
or [INAUDIBLE] for that matter.
You have the information.
You get to the moment where
you signed the contract.
And there are a few
things that you really
have to pay attention to.
The scope of processing
I mentioned absolutely
demanded by the regulators
today that the processor may not
touch the data for any
other purpose, contractually
committed.
Intellectual property, you
keep the intellectual property
of your data, seems
normal when you
think about machine learning
and the intelligence
that you will develop
using machine learning
tools on your big data sets,
very important that you also
keep that knowledge
and that doesn't
come into anybody else's hands.
Portability, when you have
developed 30 petabytes of data
in 10 years, how
do you walk out?
Are we going to help you?
How many trucks of
hard drives do we
have to bring to
the data centers?
These are literal questions
that are being asked now
with some prospects.
Very important is
the access to data
from third-party jurisdiction.
What happens if a foreign
judge asks for data
of one of your employees?
You have to get back to
the concept of controller
and processor.
In the world of the cloud
as opposed to the consumer
world of Google-- in
the world of a cloud,
we are in a very
comfortable position.
When the judge comes
to us, we say, hey,
we are only processors.
You should ask the controller,
and we redirect the request
from the judge to you,
and you decide how you
want to go with that request.
Most of the time you will want
to collaborate with justice.
Sometimes you might not want
It is really up to you.
The moment you feedback to
us a formal legal decision
that you refuse, this is
where it stops for us.
You keep on discussing with
the judge and with justice.
So, of course, there
are some French cases
where we are not allowed to
tell your employee or you
that we get requests
for the data.
Pedophilia, organized crime,
drug smuggling, imminent crime
into an investigation--
these are typical situations
where the lawmaker has provided
that there will be
no misstep to impede
into the execution of justice.
Generally the more regulated
the customer I engage with,
the more they know that.
If I engage with
a bank and there
are lawyers from the
bank in the room,
they just nod and
say yes, proceed.
We also have these-- probably
have these cases as often
as we do, and this is--
we are not above the law.
We do publish the
number of cases--
I need to hurry up.
I'm out of time.
I hope I'm not too slow.
We do publish all
the cases where
we get these requests in what we
call the transparency reports.
If you are interested in that,
Google transparency reports,
all large players have
done this by now also,
and you can find transparency
reports from Twitter
and other organizations.
But you find by country,
by year how many requests
have been executed.
It's interesting when you--
I presented yesterday in Germany
and the Germans are very, very
adamant on how much America
can look into their systems,
and I pointed to
the report and said,
you should go and check
out because America
made 13,000 requests
slides last year.
Germany made close to 10,000.
And France, which is also very
reactive, made close to 9,000.
So all of a sudden you
realize how important
it is to put your data
into an infrastructure that
wants to defend everybody
the same way independently
of the local perception of who
wants to access what data when.
So security and our commitments
to keep the certifications
that we talked about throughout
the duration of the agreement--
we don't just achieve a
certification, let you sign,
and then drop it.
And of course, audit rights
is a very important topic,
depending on the sector
where you operate in
and your lawyers will be more
or less adamant on these close.
But in summary, these contracts
allow you to come and verify
that we do what we say we do.
Of course, we don't like to
have 6 million customers walking
across our data centers.
So this is not
what is happening.
You will not have access
to our data centers.
But we have mechanisms
which allow you to check--
have access to the
detailed reports
and then propose
some new controls.
If some controls
have not been done
and you're not satisfied
with the audit,
you can inject new controls that
will be included into the audit
form for the next cycle.
At this point we have reached
the European discussion.
Will it even fit with
the European law?
And here it's always
useful, I find,
to summarize what the
European law actually says.
Still today the handling
of personal data in Europe
is regulated by a
directive of '95,
1995 that very
specifically says it is not
allowed to export European
data unless adequate safety
measures are in place,
quoting the law, probably
hopefully exactly.
Should have reviewed
the text before.
But these adequate
safety measures
are summarized in the
safe harbor, which
was invalidated last year,
replaced by Privacy Shield.
Privacy Shield is
heavily debated.
European activist
thinks it's not OK.
Trump Administration
At least these two
agree on this topic.
But it doesn't really matter
because all large cloud
providers, of course, rely
on Privacy Shield as one
of the mechanisms
that is fully--
gives the full title
to export data.
But all cloud providers use
the model contract clauses,
and these are 12 clauses that
have been devised by the data
privacy authorities of Europe
and they proposed model clauses
that all cloud providers
should add to their contract.
If these clauses are
added to their contract,
there is no more discussion.
You may export data, personal
data outside of Europe.
So these model contract
clauses come in two shapes.
I wanted to check what
slide I had behind,
and now you won't go back.
Either step model contract
clauses or model contract
clauses that have been approved
by the common opinion process,
and the common opinion process
is a process through which
the cloud providers proposes
these model contract
clauses to the regulator,
and the regulator officially
approves these clauses
and they are binding.
And there is no way a data
privacy authority around Europe
can then change his opinion
and say, oh, by the way,
no, you can't use
Google, and you
have to keep data in my
country when you use Google.
This is a binding opinion,
including for Norway.
Then comes the GDPR.
The GDPR will replace
the directive of 1995,
and it is very
important for all of you
to receive that commitment.
The deadline of
GDPR is coming fast.
By May 2018 this new
regulation will be enforced.
And what the GDPR does--
it increases the power of
the data privacy authorities
to inspect what is being
done with the data, what you
do with your users'
data and your employees'
data and your customers' data,
what we do with your data,
and all of your
stakeholders' data.
So the data privacy authorities
have gained a lot of power,
and they have also gained
very impressive tools
in terms of fines
that can go up to 4%
of the yearly global revenue
of your company per incident.
Some banks have many incidents.
Anything has many incidents I'm
not saying anything on banks
here.
So a lot of emotions.
In general on the positive
side, I personally
think that usually
Europe is always
lagging behind the
United States when
it comes to digital revolution,
digital transformation.
For once that we do
something that really matters
and that really the rest
of the world is looking at,
we should be proud as
European of the GDPR,
and we should
really embrace this
as an opportunity to raise the
trust of our entire society
in the digital world
and use this legislation
to accelerate adoption.
This is, by the way,
what we see now.
We see an acceleration of the
demand for cloud services.
Because of the increased
risk and some--
many stakeholders see
an opportunity, too.
Key for the GDPR is
that the GDPR does not
change the rules for
international data transfers.
So again, Google
Article 46 of the GDPR--
because this is very
emotional and people
have completely different
opinions and ideas about it,
the text is there.
Article 46 of the GDPR very
clearly states, a controller
or processor may
transfer personal data
to a third country or
international organization
if the controller or
processor has provided
appropriate safeguards which
can take the shape of something
like the Privacy
Shield, model contract
clauses, or new mechanisms
like code of conduct
and certification mechanisms
that will come into place when
the GDPR is launched.
And Google is actively engaged
into these other processes
to make sure that even if
Privacy Shield falls, even
if model contract
clauses would fall,
there would be other
mechanisms available.
I don't think I want to
repeat the advice I gave
this morning about
segmenting your decision
process into a technical
risk assessment,
a legal risk assessment, a
political risk assessment
is your country or any
of the countries you're
active in engaging
to data localization
legislation like
Russia, like China
and others in the Middle East.
You need to have a
cloud provider that
can at the same time deliver
the service in these countries
and risk-- and protect your
information in these countries.
And of course, the cultural
risk is the fourth one.
You might be forced to
keep data in country
because of cultural reasons.
This is perfectly
normal, but make sure
that you make a distinction
between these four layers
when you make this decision
because sometimes things
get confused, and
you might think you
might be taking the wrong
technical and legal decision
because of a cultural decision.
I will go quickly over
these ones because I want--
I touched upon
this this morning.
So I want to have more
time on the personal tools.
Again, what I was trying
to convey this morning
was in the areas
of responsibility
that you keep even in terms
of security and compliance,
even as you move to the cloud--
and you know, if you use
infrastructure as a service,
you still have a lot of
things that your customers
and your regulators
will be expecting
you to do in terms of--
you can benefit
from technologies.
I spoke about authentication,
strong authentication.
The security keys and
two-step authentication
are very important to easily
improve your security stance.
Encryption-- one of the
benefits of moving to the cloud
and moving to Google's
Cloud specifically,
you benefit from
encryption out of the box.
You can either trust
us to manage your keys.
If you don't, you can
manage your keys yourself.
And if you don't trust us to
even have access to the keys,
you can also bring
your own keys,
and we don't have any
access to the data at all.
Don't lose the keys.
This is serious.
I mean, our guys are really
panicked about customers
losing the keys
and then the media
going Google lost the data.
And then we talked
about DLP API.
The example that I gave very
briefly this morning about you
as an employee organizing
a party for your children
through your corporate
email and then this
being archived in
the corporate archive
and then coming
back 10 years ago--
10 years later and the
regulator asking your company
why did you keep the email
addresses of these children
in your email is a real question
we received from a customer.
This is the real situation.
This is to tell how complex
this is going to become.
And this is where advanced
technology can really help you.
And you had a demo
this morning, but this
is an animation of the DLP API
scanning through a live chat
box, also when you see
the feed coming in.
As the credit card
number is being typed,
it is being flagged.
And so this technology
can be applied.
You can think of plugging
this through our APIs
into your technology
and addressing
some of the big
challenges that are
coming-- that are coming ahead.
I want to summarize.
Who knows this tool?
All right, this is
Netherlands day.
You all knew-- you know
everything already.
So if you don't know this tool,
it's funny because there is--
no, I'm not going to make
a regional distinction.
This is going the wrong way.
If you don't know this
tool, go to this tool
as soon as you can, type
your email address in
and see how many times your
login credentials have been
put up for sale on the web.
If they are out there and
you're reusing the password that
was associated to that login at
the time, you have a problem.
You should not
reuse your password
on different properties.
To help you do that, install
Password Alert, which
is a Chrome extension on
Chrome that will automatically
detect whenever you
reuse your password,
and stop you from doing that.
If you install this
in your organization,
in your enterprise, it will
also warn your administrator
that you have reused
your corporate password
for another property,
and it will immediately
deactivate your password.
At Google we don't change
passwords every 60, 90 days.
I haven't changed my
passwords in many years
because I was
caught three times,
and I am not caught anymore.
I never reuse my
corporate passwords.
I know it very well, and
that's what you need.
And then lastly, second
step authentication--
if you're not using second
step authentication today
and you're still relying
on your passwords
to protect you online, you're
not acting responsibly.
You should activate second
step authentication,
and you should activate
hardware based--
I put the FIDO logo.
The FIDO is a global alliance
in which we participate
that develop the
standards, and these FIDO
enabled keys allow you to
bring a second factor that
is un-fishable.
It's basically a
cryptographic signature
that leaves your
computer to the servers
as opposed to standard
two-step authentication
when you have to type in a code.
This code can be key logged.
This code can be captured by
a man in the middle attack.
The second factor--
traditional second factor
has weaknesses that are being
abused increasingly now,
and this is how we
protect Google now
for the last four years.
And this is available on Gmail.
You can order one
of those on Amazon,
cost between $6 and $15.
You receive it, you activate
it, you pair it to Gmail,
and then you have a key for
your home, a key for your car,
and a key for your data.
And you don't really mind
if your password disappears.
Any questions?
I don't know if we have
time for questions.
We don't have time
for questions.
[APPLAUSE]